hello everyone and welcome to a really
fun game from round 15 of the
yesterday's Chinese Memorial
it's Magnus cross and versus Alexander
he shook and well let's just dive
straight into it
so Magnus opens with E 4 and the Grisha
was 4 C 5 the Sicilian defense we have
Knight f3 d6 and Bishop to b5 with check
so the canal attack we have Knight to d7
and the c3 now preparing to strike in
the center would be 4 but Knight of 6 is
going after the e4 pawn and now Queen to
e 2 defending the e4 pawn we have a 6
asking do you want to trade or go back
with the bishop and Magnus goes back
with Bishop 2 a 4 B 5 further expanding
on the Queen side and Bishop back to c2
now we have Bishop to b7 adding another
attacker to d4 pawn and Magnus just
castles here we have g6 beggary shook
and d4 now as a d4 pawn is nicely
protected with Bishop to g7 and there
are a few moves that are known here in
the database but b3 the move crossing
place is a new move in the position so
already as a move 10 we have a
completely new game now we have castles
by Greece shook and the Bishop to b2
continuing development and now II five
going after that d4 pawn we have d5
Magnus decides to close the center and
now Knight to h5 shifting the night over
to f4 but also maybe making room for for
the F pawn so g3 not allowing Knight f4
and now Knight to b6 we have a four kind
of trying to gain more control of the C
4 square but black just continues with
f5 and here C 4 now a threatening to win
the b5 pawn be captures on c4 we have B
captures on c4 and now pushing the pawn
further with f4 and here Magnus goes for
a5 askings very shook what do you want
to do here do you want to go back with
the knight or maybe go for something
else now the the critical idea is F
captures in g3 which is very complicated
and maybe requires a bit too much
calculation for a blitz game point being
that after the knight is captured you
can go Knight f4 attack the Queen and
after the Queen moves you go g2 but it's
really complicated and
it's hard to evaluate who who comes up
on top here for example night h3 check
you give up the pawn and I'll Queen d7
defends the night going to g4 and it's
well really really complicated so
instead the goalie shook first moves the
knight with Knight to d7 and now g4 no
longer allowing this idea Knight back to
have six and now even g5 the opponent g5
is a bit advanced but is protected by
the knight so it's not a problem Knight
to h5 and now King to h1 making room for
the rook to come to the g5 if needed
we've looked at seven by grace shook and
Knight B to d2 now continuing
development end now h6 going after that
g5 pawn so look to g1 adding another
defender and here now I agree shook
should have gone for a king to h7 but
it's really hard to realize why from
this position
I agree should be instead added another
defender to the g6 pawn this way good
night to f8
however this loses the game on the spot
but it's a really tricky tactic so feel
free to pause the video and try to
figure out how to win this with white
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting the idea as
it's not an easy move to find and for
those of if you just wanna enjoy show
it's G captures on h6 point being you
want to get the bishop away from the G
file so this all nicely connects point
is that now now you well obviously you
have to do something in removing the
bishop or capturing it doesn't really
matter but you have to move the bishop
away from the G file so here agree
should captured it and now comes Knight
captures on e5 opening up and attack
towards the night
so here you capture it or you don't for
example if you if you don't capture if
you capture it with D captures on e5
then comes Queen captures on h5 and now
everything is hanging this is saying
this is hanging this is hanging and
there's just no no good way to play this
Bishop g7 you can even give up the
exchange here with captures captures and
captures and it just gonna be impossible
to play this rook is coming to g1 the
bishop can capture on e5 as this Bishop
is pinned the knight can easily come
into the game and it's it will just be
over very quickly
so instead after night captures an
85-degree shook through in an isolation
took with f3 attacks across since queen
but now carlson doesn't move the Queen
but rather continues with night captures
on f7 so k-f captures an e2 and now
Knight captures on d8 with rook after
sandy 8 and now Knight to f3 and if we
look at what's happening on the board it
seems that Magnus has won upon but it's
it's hard to hard to decide whether this
pawn will remain here for very long and
also he's up the exchange so Bishop the
c8 and now comes rock 81 going after the
e2 pawn with Knight to f4 defending but
now Bishop to c1 preparing to remove the
defender of the pawn king of 7 and now
Knight to g5 with check here Magnus
forces the trade because of Bishop
captures an f4 on the next move so
captures rook captures and g5 and now
Knight to h3 attacking the rook and the
pawn but Magnus not really worried about
it goes rook to g3 gives up the f2 pawn
with check King g2 and now Knight back
to g4 but now the bishop also retreats
the b2 now grabbing hold of this
diagonal and we have rook to e8 putting
more pressure to the e-file but now
finally rook cat for sunny - we have
Knight to e5 by Ganesha but now rook to
f2 with check King g7 and now rookie
cheetah f3 saying that ok your knight is
pinned you cannot capture my rook I'm
gonna go rook the f7 check next so we
have Knight to d7
getting it the other night into the game
hoping maybe to trade off some some
rocks here along the F file but now
Bishop the a4 you could go rook to f7
check right away but Magnus goes for
Bishop day for right away now adding
another pin into the game we have king
to h6 unpinning but now rook h3 check
King g7 and now Bishop captures on d7 we
have Bishop captures and only now look
back to f3 as the night is still pinned
talking back to h6 and only now does
Magnus capture Bishop captures rook
captures and now which two rooks against
rook and the bishop where Magnus is
still up upon so it's not not very
now challenging but okay Luca for
defending the pawn and the bishop today
for now we've looked a bit - now
shifting the rook the other way around
and King to h5 we have rook to b8 and
here GFI forcing the work to move to
capture d4 pawn but Magnus says it's not
a problem Luke f6 which prevents the
King from going back with King to g6
here issue captured on e4 but it simply
doesn't work so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find the winning
move for white well I'll give you a
couple of seconds it's actually a force
made into so have at it
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting rookie
Jade and for those of you just wanna
enjoy show yep that's that's the idea
so rook to hh8 with check and it was in
his position that Alexander he should
resign the game as after came to g4
which is the only move you get pawn to
h3 and that is checkmate since well that
the black king has nowhere to go
so after Luca check check Grisha
resigned and yet another victory for
Magnus understand it's invitational
Steinitz memorial sorry not invitational
and just so I don't forget here are the
final standings of the Chinese in
memorial after three days of play across
table from chess 24 the a constant wins
the tournament with two to hope points
ahead of everyone else followed by
daniil Du Bois with 10 and Peter Svidler
with 9 and a half and then as follow
Charlie remedy of Jeffrey's young
Mongolian Bhushan gee Anton gorev of
David Anthony Haro and in less place
incredibly Alexander Grichuk obviously
not not his tournament but yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it
tomorrow we are starting the Lynn Doris
Abby rapid tournament players will play
four games a day so it's gonna be a lot
of action I don't know how many games
I'll cover but if they're interesting
probably probably more than one so I
would like to thank Eric moon Roy yeah
Kyle Wurlitzer Martin buta Mark Abbott
and Tiana marine fish for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and I will
season continuing the coverage of the
Murphy saga and whatever else happens in
the chess world like I said the Linder
is a B Ches rapid tournament is starting
tomorrow so thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day